just feel like when I have my hair like
this I can do that yeah he would be a
perfect David Ayer you know sublime
character
yeah you know in the Latin gang hood
he's starring a white guy David Ayer
fashion no you're the main here and then
you're the guy showing me around a
little bit more sympathetic you know
you're the crazy suicide squads David
Ayer
reuniting with Shia LaBeouf from fury
also a lot of pariahs in this hells yeah
I don't really know her work let's watch
this man hey George Lopez
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that sound effect is in the movies whoa
taking a page out of writing Suicide
Squad
just sounded like you wanted to do that
really sounded like you wanted that
David Ayer managed to successfully
remake training day harsh time stacking
all in one movie yeah good for the guy
hey maybe this will be looks like it's
sent bright
taking his aesthetic and applying it to
like a fantasy movie maybe this will
take some of that aesthetic like you
pointed out and applied to his gangster
watching this I was reminded of
literally every street level okay David
Hayter film I've ever seen that he's
doing his Guy Ritchie thing or like he
breaks out for a little while that he
goes back to his gangster clearly yeah
out of all of them this is the one that
they're reminded me the most of his
harsh times Shia LaBeouf's character
reminds me of Christian Bale's character
he's really like the tough intimidating
scary one him and Bobby Soto it looks
like a lot of the core dynamic of it is
between their friendship that formulates
and then of course Bobby Soto he's got
his family to look after and then
there's gonna be some cool action scenes
that take place in between I feel like
I've seen all the David Ayer's movies
that he's directed if not most at is to
say the least I guess that the thing
gets a bit missing for me as a person
who is a fan of his work I'm one of the
few people who actually really like
bright you know that included I like his
movies like Street Kings like harsh
times and of watch especially I guess
the thing that's missing for me is that
I I don't quite see what he's doing
that's different like at least I love
buffs in this the Shia LaBeouf character
while Shia LaBeouf looks great like he
looks awesome and I think Shia LaBeouf
we were actually talking about this in a
recent livestream we were doing over
underrated actors and how there was a
point where Shia LaBeouf was overrated
now with the career trajectory he's had
now he's like underrated again yeah and
I think this is like one of those roles
really do get a chance to really see
like after his work that he have like
peanut butter Falcon honey boy I think a
lot of people are like dude who stole
such a great actor and
have in front of Center here and that
but the missing thing for me here as a
fan of David eaters working here this is
a matter of you guys but to me it kind
of does it doesn't look like he's doing
anything much different with it
than what I've seen him do in those
other movies already yeah this is kind
of what I expected this trailer to look
like which was exhilarating in a sense
just because you know David Ayer's
career hasn't been on the highest note
lately but yeah it kind of plays off of
everything I've come to it and yeah I
mean I guess that's one thing I just
share with you is I wish it would have
signified some kind of growth for this
genre because I don't begrudge him
sticking with it same with Guy Ritchie
is you want to see them grow within
their comfort zone or bring some kind of
newer or more mature flavor to it you
know this guy's got a family at the very
least which you know isn't the most
original way to mix that up either so I
don't know I mean I hope that this is
good I guess notice does the David Ayer
loves like lead characters who look like
him
Shia LaBeouf looks like are you sure dad
I actually don't recall any interviews
the only only footage I've seen of today
or like actual video footage of the guy
is what he says I can't recall any like
interviews I've seen with him picture
I've seen he's got that goatee but I'm
under the amuck
I'm under the impression that he fancies
himself at least when he's writing that
he is the white guy this kind of life I
feel like you did is Roberts are always
like la-based really yeah and even if
it's focusing on the cops like sabotage
or end of watch I just keep imagining
he's like one of those guys usually
writers do that where they think they
imagine themselves as this person yeah
that's what I mean what you're pointing
you'll be dead soon it's true everything
about this looks extremely familiar I
guess like the one implement that you
pointed out and sort of borrowing the
action aesthetic that he learned while
working on films like Suicide Squad and
bright it could be like some of the
action scenes because I don't recall any
specific action scenes that look like
that slow-mo effect that you see here in
those earlier street-level phones and
this but to be honest this is also kind
of the
Arina that I've been wanting David heir
to go back to after like the work wits
to do with bigger produce studio films
like Suicide Squad and bright these are
the films that had me latch on to him as
a filmmaker I feel like mmm most likely
even if it doesn't look entirely unique
from what he's done prior I'm sure it'll
be serviceable
yeah sure be good I'm sure it'll be
lived in to a degree yeah I mean I this
this is the kind of genre that he
actually excels at the pretty Shia
LaBeouf front and center what I did find
interesting and it's something to kind
of pay attention to in the credits
he's lastly credited as an Shia LaBeouf
so I'm sure maybe his character will be
super important when they said that it
actually threw me for a loop because
he's all over this trailer
he and normally it's that and famous
person name would mean that they're not
in as much as you think but they but
they play an important part over here
I'm like if he looks like the lead yeah
and I wonder if maybe the guy with the
family is the actual lead and he is
that's usually how it goes I love I was
gonna be the partner who's a prominent
character who's probably the most fun to
watch or something like that but yet
isn't the point of the story and who
will probably die ya know while the
other guy maybe gets to you know rescue
his family I mean George Lopez is in
here that's a cool serious work so
always fun watching a comedian take more
of a serious turn I noticed in the way
how he shot this movie he's been
shooting a little bit more in a wider
frame and it feels like for going for
that more personal touch everything
feels a lot more locked in hey you know
it doesn't feel extremely handheld
necessarily you'd be better described it
than I would you know cuz you understand
cinematography yeah I said of like big
wide framing it feels a little bit more
standard yeah it was a little deeper
there's a lot more yeah it seems like
they might be using longer lenses or
something to really put you in the head
city of what everyone's doing and
whoever they look
and yet a enhance some of those more
stylized shuts I would imagine and to
also like to add depth of field to make
it look like there are probably more
people in more space yeah cuz I don't
know how what the budget would be like
now on this as opposed to before Oh cap
it off for this at the end of the day
it's just a trailer at the end of the
watch wouldn't it be cool if at the end
they came in like there's just like
break in act 3 with a POV sequence bear
get an error verse with all the
different la crime there's coming
together let's see how this turns out
what do you guys think of this trailer
are you excited for it what about our
most looking forward to taking a quick
restore the comments seems like more
people are talking about Lana Parrilla
than they are talking about Shia LaBeouf
that's fascinating subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification I'll get
notified over got a YouTube video up I
have high hopes for this movie let's see
how it turns out and I think it's coming
out around the time when Suicide Squad
last but not least ascend this with a
Logan ladoo what do you know ladoo I
didn't do you for the month of June and
I'm sorry buddy I got mixed up when
making some notes I totally forgot to
give you a shout-out for life I really
was under the impression what we found
ourselves in now is a Shia LaBeouf
situation you're coming around to
collect your shoutout well here it is
I'm sorry
please don't bust the cap in my ass okay
oh let's speak like that let's not get
all gangsta we don't wanna make popping
or off or anything like that alright
thank you John seats we know the street
we grew up in the streets Los Angeles as
it's correctly pronounced I'm a gringo
he's a gringo I look Hispanic yeah that
qualifies really I belong in the streets
a Glendale knows I'm
anywhere else so long panorama city if
you want to mess around
get yourself clapped by somebody in the
Filipino community you Logan
I wanted to apologize and just say that
now you will forever be known in my eyes
as the Shia LaBeouf I hate your up it is
you are the tax collector love you buddy